Це мальовничий острів Рюген
на північному сході Німеччини. Казкові краєвиди,
море та білі крейдові скелі. Іще однією особливістю
острова Рюген є те, що тут повністю відмовилися
від спеціальних шкіл для дітей із особливими потребами.
Із 2010 року усі діти острова
ходять у звичайні школи. Експеримент показав:
навчання дітей з інвалідністю у звичайній школі
значно поліпшило їхні успіхи в читанні, правописі
та математиці.
У 2009 році Німеччина приєдналася
до Конвенції ООН, яка передбачає перехід
до інклюзивної освіти. Це означає, що жодній
дитині з інвалідністю не можуть відмовити
в навчанні у звичайній школі. І справа не лише
в тому, що у спецшколах діти
з особливими потребами відділені
від решти суспільства. Статистика теж
не на користь спеціальних шкіл: у них
дві третини дітей так і не отримують атестати,
а відповідно їм практично закритий шлях
до працевлаштування.
Інше питання: наскільки звичайні німецькі школи
пристосовані, щоб навчати дітей із інвалідністю?
Якщо говорити про цілу Німеччину, то
кардинальних змін у шкільній системі
поки не сталося. Основні причини -
недофінансування та брак персоналу.
У Німеччині нині бракує близько 40 000 вчителів,
тому приділяти увагу дітям з інвалідністю
у звичайній школі дуже складно.
Хоч спеціальних педагогів і переводять
у загальні школи, вони зазвичай були
вузькопрофільовані: вміли працювати з дітками,
які обмежені в русі або мали соціально-психологічні
обмеження тощо, тобто не з усіма видами
особливих потреб. Крім цього, не всі школи
відповідно обладнані, безбар'єрні та мають
достатньо приміщень, щоб працювати з дітьми з інвалідністю.
Перехід на інклюзивну освіту
відбувається повільно, але зрушення є.
Так, нині до звичайної школи ходять 340 тисяч
дітей з інвалідністю. Це утричі більше, ніж у 2006.
У Німеччині, порівняно з Україною,
люди з інвалідністю мають значно вищі шанси
на працевлаштування. Подивимося на статистику.
У світі є понад мільярд людей
із обмеженими можливостями.
У Німеччині у 2015 році понад мільйон людей
із інвалідністю важкого ступеня мали роботу.
Переважно в управлінні, ремісничих галузях
та медицині.
Безробітними були 13% людей
з інвалідністю важкого ступеня.
Це удвічі більше, ніж загальний показник безробіття
у суспільстві, але менше, ніж у багатьох інших країнах.
Статистика з року в рік поліпшується.
Від освіти дітей з інвалідністю дуже залежить
їхній майбутній професійний шлях,
тож експеримент на мальовничому німецькому острові Рюген -
унікальний приклад не лише для Німеччини.